justin trudeau the prime minister of
canada is in hot water again
oh boy is he in trouble
oh justin what's he in trouble for is he
in trouble for a major corruption
scandal involving a construction company
called lavaland that took place just
three years ago
that where justin trudeau was actually
formally charged with an ethics
complaint this is the from canada's top
ethics watchdog the first prime minister
in canada's history to have this happen
to him
just on paper the most corrupt prime
minister ever in the history of canada
no no it's not that
is it because he's persecuting
christians
and shutting down their churches no it's
not that is it because he's
like
canadian politicians for a very long
time permitting abortion up until the
moment of birth has some of the most
barbaric abortion laws in the entire
world
just pure infanticide no it's not that
it's because he um
oh he wore blackface once which we
already knew about that's why he's
that's the scandal
justin trudeau
who we know were blackface
now we have
another photo of him wearing blackface
from i think the same event
that's the big scandal
i do oh man i know i know this is going
to be this is going to get me in trouble
with all the left-wing groups out there
i don't i don't care that justin trudeau
wore blackface i don't i don't care at
all i don't care that jimmy fallon
or blackface neither does the left by
the way i don't care that ted danson
wore blackface neither does the left by
the way i don't care that joy behar wore
blackface neither is the left by the way
i don't care that megyn kelly talked
about blackface once and the left really
cares that's a big problem that's a
really that's you've got to lose your
career for that i don't care no one
actually cares
no nobody cares about blackface itself
people are using that
as a way to feign indignation
because
race is the only way that we can talk
about
sin
and grace
and justice and crime anymore in the
entire western world
but no one cares about the blackface
itself this is a real indictment of our
culture
that blackface is what people are
attacking justin trudeau for
on the on the long list of justin
trudeau's sins
blackface is somewhere around number
5326
okay it's not even close to the top
but i've said this before i may have
said it before on the show
the worst thing you can be called is a
racist
the only the only way we can talk about
transgressions of the moral order is in
terms of race and the reason for that is
we've adopted in many ways a materialist
view of the world so our view of the
world only runs skin deep now we deny
that god exists we deny that
a moral order exists we deny that
there's anything beyond the flesh in the
present and yet we still intuit that
some things are right and some things
are wrong so the only way that we can
discuss them is using the language of
skin as using the language of
physicality
this is why you heard around 9 11 you
heard people warning against anti-muslim
racism
as we pointed out then islam is not a
race islam is a religion so if you don't
like muslims or you object to islam
you are not doing so on the basis of
racism you're doing so on the basis of
your religious views you're doing so on
the basis of your philosophical views or
your sociological views but not racism
but that's the only way
that we can talk because we're stupid
because we've gotten extremely stupid in
this culture
and we do not possess the philosophical
or political sophistication
to debate these things is it any wonder
that increasingly we are living
in an oligarchy i'm so glad you enjoyed
that clip
if you like that oh baby the best is yet
to come you've got to check out the
whole episode you can get that here on
youtube and you can comment and
subscribe you can also get it at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
head on over there type in the michael
knowles show subscribe
you will never miss an episode i would
greatly appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you